hello and welcome to GameSpot's full
review of Mortal Kombat 11 I'm Michael
hi I'm joined by a reviewer Edmund Tran
all the way across the world in
Australia
to talk about his thoughts on the game
now we're gonna cover fighting game
mechanics from cover story The Cribs
microtransactions towers of time all
that good stuff but to kick things off I
want to hand it over to Edie to give us
kind of an overview of where you stand
with the game alright so yeah Mortal
Kombat 11 is a really great fighting
game I gave it a 9 in my final review up
for him an 8 in the review in progress
and that's partly due to you know it's
really great fighting mechanics you know
the core of any good fighting game is
the act of being another dude up and the
mechanics that you use to your advantage
in that scenario and one combat 11 is
it's a really exciting and sort of
aggressive style of fighting game which
makes it fun no matter whether you're a
pro or you're just like a casual
fighting game player looking to see some
cool fatalities and cool moves
brutality now one of my favorite parts
in world combat 11 is a story mode
because NetherRealm is kind of built a
reputation of having these cinematic
story modes where with injustice 2 and
then the previous Mortal Kombat's but I
really feel like they up their game with
Mortal Kombat 11 bring in and saw all
sorts of characters and time-travel and
all the kind of weird stuff now like I
said it was my favorite but I think we
also share the same sentiment yeah
absolutely I mean you can tell it nether
realms done a bunch of these because
this one is so polished and sort of it's
it's really entertaining blockbusters
style cinematics story mode and the
conceit this time around helps you come
and sort of get into it so the whole
deal is that there's a big baddie quick
chronica and she's messing up with time
and bringing in old characters from
Mortal Kombat to meet the current day
counterparts and that creates a whole
bunch of interesting scenarios where
even if you're not up to date on the
Mortal Kombat law which you know let's
let's be fair like not a lot of people
are you can still appreciate seeing
characters that you kind of recognize
like you know you're Liu Kang sneers
observers and seeing them get into like
these wacky situations where they're
fighting themselves fighting their
future selves getting to also to like
weed deadly alliances and on like kind
of stuff it's actually pretty surprising
because there are some interesting
moments of like introspection and like
this story manages to make you care
about the characters in sort of weird
ways that did not expect to but at the
same time it's also fun to just sit back
and watch a bunch of cool fight scenes
of like Liu Kang taking you on like a
thousand demons or whatever you like to
be watching a lot more fight scenes than
you will be participating in them but
it's really well done the choreography
is great it visually it looks like
really impressive like some of the
facial animations I was like really like
taken aback by there's a lot of subtlety
there which is weird to say for Mortal
Kombat game younger us solemnly swear to
tapped at the earliest opportunity
what it's our destiny
yeah like story mode is definitely one
of the big highlights of Mortal Kombat
11 and yeah it's only three to four
hours that it is something that I
thoroughly enjoyed and you thoroughly
enjoy it I think a lot of people will
thoroughly enjoy now this is a fighting
game after all so it lives or dies by
how well it plays so run us through how
you feel about the mechanics and
actually playing this game
yeah the mechanics are really easy to
get into and like you said the story
mode is a really great way to sort of
get a feeling of the some of the more
popular characters that will lead you
into and during the game sort of in the
long tail motor combats fighting system
is always kind of being more on the
accessible side it doesn't it's not as
demanding on sort of Special Move inputs
as say your straight batters or your
Tekken's but it does have a few
satisfying sort of avenues for you to
sort of national feed buttons and get an
exciting outcome so I love those chrome
best strings are predetermined and if
you hit buttons in a certain combination
you will get a guaranteed combo string
which you can build off and later in the
game and the game does a really good job
instead of teaching you how to do that
so there have been a few changes since
Mortal Kombat X to make thought to make
the game I feel a little bit more
accessible so the meter system is a
little different in welcome at X you had
a three tiered meter system which
allowed you to do sort of special things
in the fight once you hit a certain
threshold and that was that was a good
system but it was a little confusing to
know when you know say you could do a
combo breaker you know you had to build
up two meters special power to be able
to do that in Mortal Kombat 11 it's a
lot more simplified it sort of looks a
little more complicated at first there's
a separate meet at the defensive
maneuvers and a separate meter for
offensive maneuvers the reason why it
works so well is that you start the
match with full meter and that sort of
encourages you to use technique like
amplified special moves so when you do a
special move you can hit r1 to use a
borrowed meter which you'll already have
to sort of give it a little bit of extra
damage or extra property and sort of
open up your options in a fight same
with the defensive maneuver you will
always have a
a bank of defensive meter to sort of get
out of a long combo string if someone's
struggling you in the air you can just
hit down an r2 to insulate escape from
that and that creates a sort of a much
faster paced dynamic to Mortal Kombat 11
which which keeps matches like really
fun and sort of gets things exploding
right out of the gate x-ray moves have
also been kind of kind of changed from
monochrome addicts they are now these
things called fatal blows which are
essentially your super moves if you're
familiar with other fighting games but
the way they work is that you can only
really use federal blows when you're the
low 30% help so it's a combat mechanic
and it's a comic mechanic that's really
easy to execute you just have to hit two
shoulder buttons so it adds a bit of a
tension to a match when you see your
opponent is low and health has their
fatal blow available and they can very
easily get it on you if you're really
careless the you know the thing is with
fatal blows is that you can only use it
once per match so if you use it in the
first round and then you sort of lose
that round you don't get access to it so
it's a it's a it's a great dynamic of
like do I use it here do I keep it do I
play my games with my opponent too like
trying to trick them into do something
silly to try and avoid a potential fatal
blow and that's basically it there are a
few more more advanced techniques like
sort of flawless blocking which sort of
discourages people from like blocking
too much and sort of playing a overly
defensive game and yeah that that all of
that sort of feeds into the fact that
will come at 11 want you to get in there
and start hitting dudes like always be
within a striking distance because if
you're not you know you're gonna get you
know pounds doing yeah it for me it took
some time to get used to the mechanics
because coming from anime fighters I
played a lot blazblue I play a lot of
under night in birth so moving to Mortal
Kombat 11 I was like oh it's a little
slow I can't really wrap my head around
it but once I did get into rhythm with
it
I kind of was able to figure out okay I
have these very streamlined mechanics at
my disposal it from there it's just this
competitive mind game whether it's tough
AI or if it's people online and I
not really fun to engage with because of
how smooth everything flowed whether
it's two animations or the response time
between my combos and what I'm trying to
do in terms of juggling and stuff like
that but to get to that point whether
you're a beginner or a veteran you have
to go through the tutorials because they
pretty much lay out everything for you
it's an extension of what NetherRealm
did with injustice - but even more
in-depth here with Mortal Kombat 11 so
it doesn't matter what skill level you
are jump into the tutorials and you'll
learn everything from when to use fatal
blows how to use fail blows but also
frame timings how to juggle how to
escape juggles like you were mentioning
with break ways so so what are your
thoughts on the tutorials yeah like the
toys are really fantastic and I said in
my review that Mortal Kombat 11 is
probably a really good entry point for
anyone who's kind of like interested in
fighting games because it teaches you a
lot of sort of techniques instead of
technical jargon and sort of mindsets
that you can easily take to any other
fighting game you know even you and me
who play a lot of fighting games and you
know I play a lot of different
franchises you know yeah Mortal Kombat
is its own base it's a very it is a very
sort of rigid and sort of slower paced
fighting game compared to like anime
fighters like or even like you take it
to the street fighters so it does take
some time getting used to it's it's it's
not a game where you can kind of waste a
move it's a very precise planning game
when you yeah you can't whip otherwise
you get punished really bad so going
into the tutorials even if you're you
know fighting a veteran is a worthwhile
thing because it teaches you so much and
it goes is just so much detail the
tutorials will go from like your bare
burn basics like how do you move back
and forward how do you put throw a punch
how do you do a kick and then it sort of
moves into sort of like how to do a
special move and then teaching me the
specifics of the meter system and sort
of the break ways and the techniques can
do that but what really impressed me was
how comprehensive the advanced stuff was
so it starts teaching you how to do
things like build combos and sort of
think about positioning and it doesn't
just throw you in a matching give you
sort of like a button prompt to like hit
it will actually just have text
says hey here's how you build a combo
this is the theory behind it and this is
what you can potentially do in a real
match to sort of follow up with that now
look at this look what you're doing and
sort of see what happens and then it
will even give you examples of like now
try this see why that doesn't work and
sort of and sort of understand that and
take that away with you as well and then
getting into more advanced they're like
frame data you know that's the kind of
stuff that was has always kind of been a
little bit hidden and you know the stuff
that you kind of need to go on the
internet and sort of find that
information on like how many frames is
the start up this dish removable how
long is it lost and you know how long is
it invincible for here it's all just
kind of just laid out and the tutorials
actually teach you how to use that and
interpret that and like visually
explained to you okay this is what a
start up looks like it's blue you can
see that it's starting up this is what
happens when that occurs and here's how
you can use it to your advantage like
and pits like certain moves against
certain moves and it makes you
understand this one will beat this one
because it's faster to execute and so on
and so forth and then it goes into more
and more examples of how you can use
that information it matches to get an
advantage keep pressure up create flame
traps and it can you know to someone who
doesn't pay fighting games it can be
pretty overwhelming but I feel like it's
dulled that in a really smart and
intelligent way and what'll come at
11:00 sort of gives you the information
and tools throughout all of its sort of
UI and sort of information and move
lists to keep you thinking about that
and sort of keep giving you that
information and encouraging you to get
better at the game and think about it in
these more advanced ways because it's
all right there like when hit start and
go to your move list you can see or that
dot and it's like oh okay this one's a
really fast move to get out so maybe
I'll rely more on this one when you know
someone whips a move oh that's a quick
punish it goes one further with the
character specific tutorials as well
which sort of builds on all the advanced
knowledge you know all the fighting
games have character specific tutorials
where they just run through the move
lists and sort of get you to do the
moves and sort of see what they look
like the more incumbent eleven sort of
condenses that and you know some people
might not like this as much but you know
I thought it was a really great way to
go about character tutorials it focuses
on around
ten specific moves and all
bread-and-butter combos that you can
that are the most useful in a fight and
it will explain to you this is useful
for keeping space or this is useful
because it starts with quickly and it's
safe on block so if you use it and you
you're kind of blocks it you're still
okay or it will say this is a great move
but it's really dangerous and they give
you suggestions on sort of how to build
upon that knowledge as well which I find
is a really good way to encourage people
to sort of keep thinking about finding
games in that way
to the good tutorials very good MK 11
has so much content and a lot of that
revolves around the towers of time which
are evolving challenges in the game now
it's interesting because the towers of
time are very different now from what
they were at launch now I want to get
your thoughts on that
yeah the towers of time of [ __ ] at
launch they were they were unfair they
were really frustrating to play through
and I had a lot of control of throwing
moments before the game actually lost
officially so the towers in mortal
combat are a series of fights that you
can take on and you know they will pit
you against pottering and spider and the
classic towers sort of just line them up
for you to knock them down so the towers
of time in other realms sort of online
sort of persistent content where they
are on a timer and they rotate every day
or every few hours and get new
challenges and the towers of time add
modifiers to these fights so these could
be things like the state is on fire or
when an opponent punches you you get
poisoned or your opponent has an assist
character who can do extra damage so
these things aren't surprised in other
all games they've done them before that
in Mortal Kombat 11 at launch these
modifiers were so unbalanced it was
almost impossible to sort of get through
one without you know pointing your hair
out modifiers that affected the
environment like missiles raining down
from the sky or like you know a blizzard
freezing you would only affect you and
not your AI opponent which meant the
odds were always against you like no
matter what and you think in Mortal
Kombat 11 is consumables so they added
this thing where you can get item drops
from as rewards from playing the game
and you would use these in Tarot time
fights just sort of even the odds
so if
raining down missiles you would maybe
like get an assist character or if it
was a blizzard you would get a thing
that sort of stops you from freezing
every once in a while that in its launch
state like these did not help at all
like you know there's a there was a
modifier that was utter utter [ __ ]
which was make the stage completely
black like pitch black you can't see a
damn thing
so like there would be a missile coming
out of the sky and it would hit you and
they're screaming just go pitch black of
five seconds you just couldn't do
anything your mind goes to think that
okay I use the item that stops me from
getting affected by dark things and like
okay and you use it and it only works
for like one or two missiles before it
starts happening again and the cooldown
of these things was so long that yeah
like the tells the time was just a bad a
venire to sort of play the game like it
was almost impossible to get to the end
of one and get the rewards after it and
that's what made them so frustrating it
was it was difficult it was unfun and
you didn't get rewards for doing any of
that but almost immediately after the
review was published like you know a lot
of other people were saying the same
thing and then the room immediately
almost immediately in a combat car said
like okay we completely ignored that all
the stuff is broke where you're gonna
fix it no worries so they we spent the
week rolling out a few server-side
changes and as of yesterday they
released a full patch for PlayStation
which is currently rolling out on other
platforms which really really makes
things a whole lot better so they did a
lot of things like reduce AI sort of
health pools to sort of normalize it to
be to feel more like a regular fight
they would use to AI difficulty they
removed a lot of the garbage modifiers
that were just unfair they may cool down
on the consumables a lot faster and they
increase the rewards that you get from
almost anything in the game to be you
know worthwhile like something that
would usually get you a hundred coins
would now get you a thousand you know
the rewards at the end of a tower would
get you like you know a few hundred
hearts so unlike guaranteed costumes and
like what's a really good stuff and so
now as they stand the towers of time are
at just an interesting way to sort of
enhance sort of your in-game experience
and what'll come back they're fun fights
that are completely manageable even with
the modifiers like assists and you can
still use consumable
to give you a leg up that I play for a
good solid 5 or 6 hours yesterday and I
was just like clearing out these towels
without any consumables like if you're
playing on point and you know how to
sort of defend against the modifiers
that are being put against you you could
easily take these on and so I was like
raking in the rewards yesterday and like
yeah these are really fun because the
prizes at the end of the tunnel like
always feel like right there like like I
can play these five guys and get like a
bunch of cool cautions at the end of it
like that always feels manageable in
fact now there are certain towers and
islands that are just one fight like
there are these boss fights that put you
up again it's like a really tough
opponent but you only need to enjoy them
for like one round now and like if you
survive that one round you get a bunch
of good stuff and there are some other
interesting boss fights that have you
and two other online players go up
against like one other opponent like
who's really tough and yet these these
boss fights are still a slug but yeah
like I said it's one round and you get a
bunch of cool stuff at the end of it and
finishing towels doesn't feel as
impossible as it once did and they've
really turned it around on that towers
the time are also an evolving thing too
so NetherRealm is constantly gonna be
swapping out different challenges so
this really helps the longevity of
Mortal Kombat 11 I believe I want to see
where they go in the future with these
towers of time because I feel like they
really got the message and improved on
it and delivered kind of the type of
experience you'd want out of this game
and also delivering variety to now a lot
of that is also relegated to the Crypt
now there's a ton of gear costumes
cosmetics extra consumables a whole
bunch of different content to customize
your characters your combat card and
even unlock fatalities brutalities and
all that good stuff and a lot of that is
either you unlock it through the Crypt
or in towers of time but the Crypt is
something a little bit interesting
because it's now sort of this pseudo
third-person adventure and when I was I
was playing through the Crypt I'm like
oh snap like is this a mortal kombat
slash god of war type thing this
actually kind of looks neat and kind of
feel it feels cool to walk around on
shanks UN's island and explore a bit but
the real reason you're there is to
unlock chests and spend your coins spend
your currency it also get few of MORTAL
KOMBAT
Easter eggs along the way but the Crypt
is also changed
so what are your thoughts on the Crypt
yeah I mean the clip is is stunning it's
like it's one of the coolest spots of
moral coma at 11 like yeah Shang Tsung's
Island looks really fantastic and if
you've ever played like Mortal Kombat 1
or 2 you will instantly like be like oh
damn that's like the pit
that's the Warriors shrine and it's
really cool to get a hit of nostalgia in
that respect the clip is very cool but
the way you get rewards in the crypt by
opening chests by spending your
currencies that you earn throughout the
game I'm a little I'm a little divided
on that so most of the chests that you
open in the crypt for rewards are
completely random so there are three
types of chests there are coin chest
soul chest and heart chests and the only
ones that have guaranteed specific
rewards are the heart chests and that
happens to be the hardest currency to
get in MK X the Crypt was kind of
predetermined so you can waltz in there
and if you had a favorite character in
mind you could easily look up a guide
online and just like go straight to
those chests and open them up whatever
you wanted but now I can only do that
with a certain with a specific number of
chests and which you know take a lot of
effort to earn because the currency is
rarer so yeah a lot of the clip is you
running through and opening up these
studio loot boxes which can be a little
frustrating you know no one likes
randomness especially in a fighting game
with so many unlockable things like
variation icons you know concept art
costumes gear pieces if you have a
favorite character in mind you want
stuff for that character so that
randomness can be very frustrating there
are avenues to do that I mean you can
get rewards from the towers a time which
shows you what you might be getting from
a particular challenge and you can buy
them with the premium currency in a
rotating store you know the premium
currency that you also earn through
playing the game sometimes I think I was
more bummed about the Crypt pre patch
the post patch the current the rewards
you get are so much more generous even
after like a bad crypt run I can just go
back to thank the Terra's for a couple
of hours and stockpile a bunch of stuff
to go back and tear through the crypt
again so the random aspect of the maguey
progression and
is a bit of a bummer but the way that
more comment 11 has increase its reward
allowing me to go back to the Crips more
often feels like kind of resolved a bit
of that it's not perfect but it's not
exactly a deal-breaker anymore so we've
covered so much content in MK 11 because
there is so much but one of the things
that really helps the longevity
including some of these rotating events
like towers of time and rewards is the
competitive aspect playing online
connectivity issues and stuff like that
really can make or break a fighting game
but in your experience all the online
competitive stuff seems to have gone
quite smoothly the online experience in
MK 11 I have not had any problems with
that whatsoever all the matches I played
online on sort of peace for PC and
switch they've all been like really
smooth it does some interesting things
with the casual matchmaking side where
before you get into a match you can see
who your opponent is what their win
ratio is like your chances of winning
the type of connection they have your
ping and all that kind of good stuff to
sort of make a decision whether you want
to get into that fight or not so if you
roll up and someone has like a 300 ping
you're like nah you know screw that get
the next guy you can do that and I
really appreciate that especially when I
want to only play like good online
matches it also has a ranked matchmaking
mode which is great it puts you in a
best-of-three and I found that the sort
of skill matchmaking has been pretty
good like all the bikes I've fallen into
have kind of been that 50/50 chance more
or less which makes for some you know
really tense close matches and that's
kind of what you want you want to be on
your edge at all time you don't you
don't want to be trancing people you
know all day you want a bit of a
challenge and that's what online gives
you that's it there is a lot of other
online stuff in Mortal Kombat 11 that
you know might piss some people off the
game is basically always online attract
its progression through Mortal Kombat
service so everything from your story
progression to your tutorial progression
to online modes obviously are all
trapped in via in other realms servers
so if you lose your internet connection
you could lose half your progression in
the towers
if you're in the middle of one and that
can happen even if you are in the middle
of the tower and then you back out to
the dashboard to you know post a
screenshot it will just cut your
connection and that's kind of irritating
if you're on PC or like a console and
you know it's always connected to the
internet like that kind of irritation
more like mostly be rare but obviously
certain people have different situations
some people can't always be online and
if you're offline you can only access
certain modes like story tutorial but
you know you won't get rewards for those
things this is also an issue on switch
where you know most switch players play
handheld and and Wi-Fi can sometimes be
spotty so you might be like just playing
MK 11 around the house and you might
lose connection in the middle of a fight
and that you're done and that can be
really frustrating yeah and speaking of
switch I feel like I should mention that
the switch version you know you might
expect this but the switch version looks
drastically worse than the PC and ps4
versions going into it you know you
might think you know I'm willing to take
that hit you know it so long as the game
for for on the spine that's great and
you know the fights in on the switch
version do perform you know great
they're at 60fps there are the odd
occasions where it will hit like during
sort of on cutscene transitions or
fatality transitions or you know doing
story mode and stuff like that but the
the core fighting is smooth but the
visual fidelity is sort of a lot lower
than you what you might expect from the
switch like all the cars are very very
washed out there is no contrast at all
and it's a bummer because part of what
makes more coming 11th grade is how good
it looks you know and the sort of
cinematic aspect of its visual flair and
all that kind of stuff
it looks gory because it's believable
and on switch you just don't get that at
all it's it's really most egregious in
the crypt which sort of banks on it's
visual splendor on you know the main
platforms and on switch you know you
can't yeah you can't see more than the
few feet in front of you there's just
like a thick fog that you know it's
crazy it's like is it like playing like
Silent Hill here or what it's it's
insane you know it's not that's just not
that's not just a knock on the switch
because you know switch has had really
great triple-a ports like do and wolf it
and stuff like that it's a bummer to see
more combat not perform as well on
switch because this would have been a
really great game sort of practice on
the go and the online thing in the
visual fidelity thing just makes it you
know a bit of a disappointment that
about does it for Ed's full review of
Mortal Kombat 11 and you can check out
the written version on the site and we
have the game covered from so many
different angles so head on over to
GameSpot calm and check out all that
good stuff thanks for watching